la calanque dans vos entre marseille et
cassis passe pour être secrète et
sauvage entre tout mais quand le cinéma
s'en mêle bref il y avait beaucoup de
monde à vanves hauts et du très beau
monde mylène demongeot et jean marais
aux ordres du metteur en scène andré
ulmann et leurs complices du film louis
de funès
jean marc est toujours transformée et
maquillée pour les besoins du double
personnage qui est le sien quand il est
journaliste et en hélicoptère il
poursuit fantômas car fantômas revient
sur nos écrans avec des aventures plus
que jamais prodigieuse et résolument
mise au goût du jour
l'hélicoptère en question et même un
bathyscaphe qui remplace avantageusement
des poursuites en voiture
et quand jean marais se retrouvent
déguisé gardiens de prison c'est alors
qu'il est faux thomas un fantômas qui
court comme un jeune homme s'autorise
sans doublage toutes les fantaisies pour
échapper dans la bonne tradition à ses
poursuivants acharné à saper ce qui nous
promet en toute logique de nouvelles
aventures de fantômas pendant quelques
années
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]